hey what's up guys my name is a channel
up to episode 68 of game programming so
today we're gonna freakin make our
little projectile okay so last time well
yeah we basically just took a little bit
basically you know retrieving this angle
here and obviously that's given to us in
radians by there are few things I didn't
really clear up that you guys might not
have probably enjoyed last time and
basically what I didn't talk about is
the actual difference between eight I
did cover the difference between a 10 on
a 10 or and sorry a 10 and a 10 - right
so you might notice that math dot I'll
just put this up now
mouths dot a town just a town only has
one variable and you guys were like oh
sorry one parameter and you guys were
like why is that and basically the
reason is you just input it like this
right so you just go dy / DX all right
as you would cuz the same thing right
imagine this is ten minus one and then
you put in your equation here right this
is just the same as your calculator as
any scientific calculator really here
they divided into two parameters and
like as I mentioned in last in the last
episode and the reason they do that
again is because it basically says if DX
is zero then we cannot divide by DX you
know because otherwise if we just try
and do this now we will still get that
error even before it goes into that
function right but if it's separated
then it just says okay divided by that
only if that is not zero for zero then
just return something else okay that's
what it does cool just a town the other
thing is obviously this is given to us
in radians all our calculations will
basically be done in radians we probably
will convert a degrees at one point or
another but again conversion to degrees
is actually possible in a bunch of
different ways I just like to um
basically say that you know it's just
equal to times 180 divided by math dot
pi that's just literally the maths
operation right so you could just do it
that way and if I just display that here
you'll see I'm the angle here will
actually reflect that but is that even
right I think that's right
yeah that's right you could also do the
good old now I think there's a maths up
two degrees yeah there's a
so you can do that as well and you can
see if that will permit to give us the
same answer so there's ways to do it but
we'll talk about it in a minute yeah and
the reason the other thing is this is
kind of wrong I do realize that I'm
sorry I did make a mistake so the width
and height is obviously you know
dependent on our scale because um when
we use the mouse functions to actually
get the location of the mouse on the
screen it will get that location based
off of this window not off of our
buffered image object so in other words
our buffered image object our buffered
image is 300 but wants to say but our
window size is 900 by whatever-the-hell
three times that is okay so we need to
just make sure that we do that so it's
really 300 and we should do that we
should just use them again dealt with
times that is the wrong width variable
is this private you know well that's
quickly it is public but I think we'll
make it private and just make the getter
inside of just some guys so we'll make
these all private and over here I hope
that doesn't create a million areas not
an awesome and over here we'll just add
we'll just quickly add a public static
and cold get with you know we're kept
real trend with time scale okay
hopefully static and to get Heights and
we'll return height sometimes scalp all
right
and what's up here
where's getting wet from and scale from
oh damn yeah okay get window it with I
guess that's really annoying is not
because component sorry um canvas has a
method called that okay that's fine I
guess get window with and put it here so
it'll just be mmm game yet window width
divided by 2 and game dog yeah window
height divided over 2
all right cool so that's now actually
give us proper inner results and I think
it is unarmed son sure let's just
quickly convert it back into um it's
great so that we can actually see what
we're doing ok so that's 0 good that's
90 that's 180 and then we go back down
to yeah okay that's brilliant that's
correct okay so you can see that that's
correct because um that's roughly 0 we
can see this is like 90 as it is this is
180 which is you know just PI basically
all of the angle is PI pi radians and
then we just go the opposite way right
so we go from negative now down to 0 so
yeah ok our angles absolutely correct
now one thing you might notice here
which I want to clean up today is we are
actually gonna run out of time aren't we
so there's just some amendments I'll
probably leave the actual projectile
stuff for um next episode but don't
worry cuz I'm making like an episode
every day now and you guys probably
probably think I'm dying or something
but I promise you I'm not I understand I
just had a bit more time a bit my spare
time and I do enjoy doing this so yeah
so you might say here that we've got a
bit of a problem that is if I actually
move the mouse and you can see I'm
moving mouse right now I'm dragging it
I've clicked I'm dragging it this is not
updating right we actually have to
release and then click and then a lot
date right that's not cool ok we wanted
to be able to drag and that's really
easy to fix if we go into our mouse
class already all we need to do here is
here in Mouse drives we can just set
mouse
equal to a dog get ax and the reason we
have to do that again is because mouse
moved is just when we move our mouse
right but if we actually click and drag
it it doesn't run this it runs this
instead so yeah so if we do that and
then we go back into our well we don't
need to go back anything if we were on
it then you can see that as I move it'll
update pretty much on the spot so yeah
anyway those are some those just some
basic things that I wanted to fix this
is just basically fixes from lost
episode but yeah that's basically gonna
be the UM you know how we roll
I'll see you guys tomorrow though with
the projectile stuff so we'll actually
you know how to make something on the
screen tomorrow probably anyway until
then guys if you enjoyed the video
please hit the like button and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
you